[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news I'm
Heather Ruth and I'm Anna wave and this
is your news for Monday September 25th
earlier this week director Damon Linda
Dolph released on Instagram a photo of a
statue of Nite Owl Hollis Mason night
owl which is confirming that in
pre-production right now is a watchman
miniseries on HBO and we've been talking
it was kind of teased maybe it might be
happening in July but the director kind
of pushed it aside saying that you know
if we were gonna do it I want to make
sure that it's perfect I have a lot of
respect for the source material so then
we kind of speculated maybe it won't be
happening but now it is and it's in
pre-production we'll talk now enough to
me yeah all right I mean I'm excited to
see it I'm not 100% sure we need it but
I'm excited especially if he has such
respect for the source material as a lot
of us do better have an intimate scene
set - hallelujah I'm good also that we
saw a trailer for Wes Anderson's new
film I love dogs which looks very much
like the feeling of fantastic mr. Fox
that sort of kind of animation set like
style on and it's set in Japan in a
future so that looks super adorable the
texture of everything looks gorgeous and
I'm very excited to see a new Westerners
in film yeah it looks very Wes Anderson
EEB if you know him you know we're
talking about classic like layouts of
the shots and storylines he also likes
to reuse actors voiceover actors as well
so it looks like classic Wes Anderson
and I'm very
yeah also earlier this week another
trailer came out for tomb raider well
the trailer was preceded first with a
little bit of a teaser and then a poster
and then we got the trailer and it
looked pretty cool it looks really
accurate to the newest video games which
excites me I only started playing some
of the new one and then my old computer
died and I got really sad so now man I
want to pick that back if anything I
want to play the game because this looks
it looks really fun yeah let's see if I
can dirt her whole look looks really
cool it's very neutral earth tones and
everything blends in the background very
much like Laura you know yeah and you've
got tons of slow-mo jumps packed into
that small trailer it seems like a lot
of following a lot of jumps so I'm very
interested to see how they're going to
progress her character in the film or if
they're just gonna make her be amazing
and badass all at once action action
action so yeah I mean it looks good I
don't think it looks like it is going to
be the movie that saves all video game
movies but I also don't think it looks
awful so I'll see it I'm definitely
excited for it also excited for an
action trailer was it the Punisher drop
this week that one was a really well
edited trailer had smooth sweet electric
guitar some double bass pedal you know
get you pumped up get your blood flowing
lots of blood lots of guns lots of
explosions very very very Punisher yeah
but I'm still a little nervous for it to
be honest because one of the things I
loved about him in daredevil was that he
had those amazing character moments that
I FETs felt so genuine and he was a
great counterpart to daredevil with
their moral struggle I guess against
each other so this makes it just seem
like it's gonna be a lot of action
action action action which I mean would
be fun it is it's actually not like
other Netflix shows surrounding you know
but also I'm not really sure if they're
showing the Frank Castle origin it
like we might be getting flashbacks
possibly I'm interested to see how the
layout of the show is if it's a lot of
flashbacks to his like wife B and family
being obliterated which we saw in the
first five seconds of the trailer garden
starting starting the ball rolling but
but I'd like to see some better balance
like we got kind of out of daredevil and
got to see some of his character stuff
working it's hard to show that in a
trailer so obviously our minds are open
but we'll we'll be looking forward to
that
yeah and we still don't have a release
date for it it was redacted out of the
trailer which I thought was kind of a
fun little thing to throw in there very
somatic that it was redacted out of the
trailer so 2017 question mark sure
speaking of superhero TV series are well
comic book TV series The CW released a
whole bunch of news this week about
their comic related TV series um the
first thing is that a couple of weeks
ago we mentioned that Sabrina the
Teenage Witch might be in Riverdale
turns out she's actually getting her own
show and it's going to be what they're
calling a companion show to Riverdale so
we still don't know if that means that
she'll be in it if they'll just kind of
reference each other if it'll be kind of
like the flare over in the way that they
might have crossovers every now and then
but the show is going to be called the
chilling adventures of Sabrina
based on the comic which is a lot more
down-to-earth gritty realistic and
horror themed so it might be a horror
show I'm very excited to see where they
go with it as long as they have Salem
the cat I mean me and my black cat also
in comic book trailers we got to see the
flash trailer for the season returning
and faeries back with the beard whoo
we got a little bit of teaser on
Instagram we got to see his beard for a
while
yeah that's less of a surprise however
it looks exciting
he's back there trying to save him and
bring him back well we'll see what
happens to season yeah I mean I thought
it was really kind of an odd choice at
the end of the last season spoilers
sorry everyone
too bad the end of last season he blood
went off into the Speed Force
and I thought it was kind of an odd
choice and it's even more odd I think
that they are bringing him back so
quickly in the trailer like it's all
it's kind of low stakes like we already
see him attempting to bring them back in
the trailer but show is called the flash
we could we could have the kid flash
some of us love Wally West um they also
deed for the DC CW they also released a
poster of the crossover event and you
guys you guys we're gonna have a DC
crisis yes it's not an infinite crisis
whatever it's a crisis on Earth X so in
the poster I'm in the foreground there
was a lot of things going on so in the
foreground we saw Barry and iris in
their wedding clothes so maybe this is
going to interrupt their long
anticipated wedding we don't know and
then on one side they had all the
current CW flare overs characters that
we know and love and then on the other
side they're facing off their evil
counterparts from what we can only
assume is earth X and that Supergirl
yeah she was so cool she looks so good
it looks so fun it's so cool and like
the first flash had two flashes on his
suit I don't know we're just gonna have
to wait and see um that's gonna be a
two-night crossover um so it starts on
Monday November 27th and it's gonna
start with arrow and Supergirl and then
continue on the next night with flash
and legends oh and we also saw on the
edges all the characters and they're
gonna have the live-action premiere of
the right and he's getting his own
animated series on the CW seed right now
that's in production and the same actor
who plays him as a voiceover is also
playing him in real life in the flare
overs so yeah it's an interesting I
thought it was interesting that they did
a drawn you know photo rather than an
actual live capture photo and like
edited the crap out of it like a lot of
our posters of it I thought it was a
really really nice like throwback to
comic books yeah look really beautiful
artwork
it really looks like a comic cover at
first I kind of scanned past it thinking
it was a comic cover and I was like we
know what do you cross hi I mean we've
had some issues with movie posters so I
really like that they're going back to
the artists and asking them to make
posters I think that's the right step
comic book wise and I really appreciate
that um in other news Blade Runner is
getting a whiskey yes yes
Johnny Walker is releasing a special
edition bottle that is from the movie if
you've seen Blade Runner think you know
it's the bottle it's gonna be $90
because it's very limited release
there's only gonna be 39 thousand of
these made we didn't quite even hear
when exactly it's coming out so if you
are a fan of Blade Runner or you know a
fan of Blade Runner keep your eyes open
get that whiskey I just thought for the
first time in IMAX this week and it was
pretty mind-blowing the detail was I'm
like jealous of you that you got to
experience it in iMac for the first time
ever and it was the final cut as well no
it was like the ultimate version that
you could possibly see and I saw it it
was wow it was it was quite the
experience I gotta say that's awesome
well that's about it from us here
Heather where can people can find you on
social media oh you can find me on
Twitter at Heather ruse Instagram at a
truce or twitch twitch TV slash other
roofs and as usual you can find me on
Facebook at Ayanna Wade and everywhere
else at awesome Ayanna so we'll see you
guys next week let us know what you
think about the trailer reactions down
below or what you think might be coming
up in the DC CW crossover episode we're
very excited to talk some comic book
news you know us so let us know in the
comments down below otherwise we will
catch you next week so beam us up
[Applause]
you